when we were in school growing up and
teachers would like lick their finger so
unnecessary to get like the pages to
stop sticking obviously now in colbit
like that's disgusting it's also just
like i remember being like get your
tongue away from me wench like
it was so such wenchy behavior it was
such a violation and then sometimes like
if you got your paper and you were the
top one that had like the mark on it it
was moist people handle paperwork all
the time but only teachers lifted their
fingers yeah no and their like glasses
would be at the bottom of their nose and
they would be licking and it was just
like as if school wasn't traumatizing
enough that was that was really
unnecessary